never have I ever watched porn never
have I ever been skinny-dipping
I have not you have never been
skinny-dipping no I in a pool
no I'm Your Mother I've seen you going
to pull naked no you have when you were
a baby yeah but that's that's because
you forced me into a pool naked I think
that's less skinny-dipping and more
child endangerment never have I ever
peed my pants
Pass child can embarrassing but I think
it happens never have I ever lied about
liking the present you gave me never
have I ever tried drugs you have to say
recreation yeah no yeah you definitely
have to say that okay we both have tried
drugs yes cuz your shrooms
no that was not that's shrimps of drugs
what yeah but they're natural
so is marijuana again natural never have
I ever sexted oh sure ah that came after
my time so you have a second mommy like
recently I don't think people want to
see my body
it's not just photos you could see sexy
things like oh I think you a matte like
want to do to the other person Oh what
that I want to do to the other person
actually actually never have I ever
given someone a fake phone number yeah
never have I ever snuck out of the house
when I was yeah I can say that too when
I was younger you're still young
never have I ever shoplifted oh god I
was in high school but I only took
chapstick so I don't I actually don't
consider that I took a package revenues
on the way to Hebrew school never have I
ever watched porn oh my god like what's
in there when you're younger I was in
the army how did you watch porn in the
army that's another story
all right I guess we've reached the end
of the bowl we're very similar people
but I am pretty agreed I learned that
I'm more interesting than she is I
learned she peed her pants best child
and you should be that's rad
I feel like I know everything about her
but now I'm starting to think maybe she
just knows more about me than I do about
her what that I was never in handcuffs
you watch porn
that was weird everybody has
[Music]
[Music]